hey guys welcome back I wanted to do a video on
the difference between not losing weight versus
slow weight loss and the reason is if a lot
of times we'll have people that will contact
me and they're saying I'm not losing weight
okay then I find out they are losing weight
but it's just incredibly slow so there's a huge
difference between not losing any weight at all
and losing some weight okay I mean the actions
that you would do if you weren't losing weight
are going to be completely different than what
you would do if you have slow weight loss so let's
take a look at that you put someone on the right
program and by the way I always want to make sure
that the data that someone's giving me is correct
so sometimes if they tell me I'm eating perfectly
right and I don't actually find out what they're
eating I could find out it's not perfect and that
has happened so many times also you could have
someone that is possibly cheating and they're not
telling you that's a possibility so those things
you want to rule out but the point is if they
did everything right is they're not losing weight
then you have to make a huge change okay there's
some seriously something stuck in their body it
could be with the thyroid it could be with the
adrenal could be with a kidney and that were just
requires more data more testing I need to dig deep
and find out what is behind that okay so that's
if you're not losing anything if you're having
slow weight loss it's like molasses you're losing
some but it's too gradual you don't want to make a
huge change all you want to do is strengthen the
successful actions okay so that's very different
because if I make so many changes right here all
of a sudden can turn from here to here so so we
want to look at the quality in the quantity of the
food so we look at the quality of the protein are
there doing soy protein isolates are they doing
too much protein powder is it low-fat protein
powder that actually raises insulin or what about
the quality of the fat are they doing corn oil
or or soy oil really bad quality are they doing
low quality carbohydrates are they doing sports
drinks so they're doing just pure sugar with fine
carbohydrates like refined breads and things like
so we look at the quality and then look at the
quantity the protein is it too high is it between
three to six ounces what about the fats is it too
low or maybe too high sometimes they can't they're
not used to digesting all the fat and maybe maybe
the meal is so large and the metabolism is so small
we have to adjust that some people unfortunately
have such a damaged metabolism they need to have
smaller meals or less frequent meals okay just
because everything is molasses I'll get to that
in a second so the quality and quantity of these
proteins carbohydrates and fats are vital and
then we look at the frequency of eating now are
they doing six meals a day or right there I'm
going to put them to three meals a day because
six meals a day is a lot of insulin every time
you eat by spiking insulin or maybe they're
at three maybe I need to push them down to two
meals a day okay without any like intermittent
fasting in between no anything between the meals
a lot of people are very successful with that
but there's a small group of people that just
have a very very slow metabolism that I have to
put on one meal a day now you might say that's
starvation but it's not because they're having
a very large meal all the nutrients but their
system is so slow that they can run efficiently
or should I say their system is so efficient they
can run on very small amounts of food because
it's such a slow machine so on some people we
have to do that and they eventually lose weight
because the... because the system has been
damaged over their life specially if they've been
dieting as a kid or you know ever since like like
sometimes even parents put the kids on a diet when
they're four or five years old well that's going
to really mess up things later in life okay now
the other thing we look at if it's slow is there
other body problems the quality of sleep is there
bladder waking them up is it hot flashes is it
sinus like sleep apnea do they have those issues
because it's not sleeping that's going to make it
slow I look at digestion are they constipated do
they have heartburn they have ulcers all that is
just a symptom that there is a digestive issue I
mean I'll even put people on a good probiotic and
all of a sudden they start losing weight or what
about their menstrual cycle the menstrual cycle
being too heavy that indicate too much estrogen
and that right there can stop the weight loss
too much estrogen but I don't ever support the
weight loss directly with a pill or a nutrient
because that doesn't work there's so many pills
out so that people use that say oh yeah take this
weight-loss pill that doesn't work because the
weight is always a symptom of something else so
we know most of the way problems are related to
insulin and insulin resistance so if you support
that problem you'll be way more successful the
really the only weight loss pill that I use is
something called insulin and glucose support
which is I'll put a link down there if you
want more information but it supports insulin
directly it lowers insulin and that actually
helps because in the presence of insulin you're
not going to lose weight and some people even
our pre-diabetic or diabetic they lose weight
but they still have a little insulin problem
they need some support that's when I would use
some nutrition with that okay so I just wanted
to differentiate no weight loss or slow waves
weight loss what category are you in and things
that you can do to speed things up thanks for
watching hey if you're enjoying my videos press
the subscribe button below and I will keep you
updated on the future event thank you so much